this video was made possible by
brilliant learn intuitively with
brilliant for 20% off by being one of
the first 200 to sign up at brilliant
org slash Wendover if you look up there
are four thousand seven hundred and
eight satellites that came from Earth
currently orbiting our planet just in
the portion of the sky you can see
hundreds of satellites are passing
overhead at any given time you often
can't see them but they're they're
making GPS work taking images of Earth
providing communications even spying for
governments these satellites are some of
the most expensive single objects that
can be made if you took a tennis ball
sized chunk of the Hubble Space
Telescope it would be worth over $1500
modern full-scale commercial grade
satellites cost in the hundreds of
millions of dollars they're just
incredibly complex objects that require
years to construct many of the
satellites flying over you right now
though started their life here at SSL in
Palo Alto California SSL is a commercial
company owned by Mac's our technology
specializing in satellites and
spacecraft construction they've built
spacecraft that are currently in orbit
for everyone from Direct TV to national
governments if you've ever watched
Adelaide TV listen to satellite radio or
use satellite internet on a plane
there's a decent chance you've directly
used one of the satellites they built
here in their factory but let's say you
want to buy a satellite from SSL what do
you do first thing you do is pick up the
phone and call us but the next thing you
should do is check your bank account to
make sure you have enough money to buy a
satellite satellites depending on what
kind it is and where it's going can cost
tens of millions of dollars up to
several hundred million dollars once a
customer makes that first phone call to
SSL there will be then an ongoing back
and forth between them and the customer
essentially the customer will tell SSL
what they want their satellite to do an
SSL will come back to them with a price
eventually if all goes well they'll sign
a contract that's exactly what happened
a few years ago between SSL and Telus at
a global satellite company headquartered
in Canada that owns and operates a fleet
of satellites their satellites are used
to broadcast signals whether it be TV
radio or internet for their customers
satellite TV radio and internet
providers in this case tell us
needed a satellite to provide additional
capacity over the busy North Atlantic
region and so they came and signed a
contract with SSL to build their new
satellite Telstar 19 Vantage soon after
contracts were signed work began on
designing the satellite in that process
the designers usually pull designs for
some more generic aspects from previous
projects and then modify them to suit
the particular job the length of that
process can vary widely based off how
complex the satellite is but throughout
that process as soon as they've locked a
design in they'll begin ordering parts
SSL builds about half their components
themselves and orders the other half
from other companies the decision on
whether to order or build in-house
usually comes down to performance there
are certain components where depending
on what the requirements are we build
higher performance components than
suppliers some of them are suppliers
build better components than Legion over
the years SSL has looked at what it's
good at and what other suppliers are
good at and made the decision on what to
order based off that for example one of
the components that SSL builds are the
antenna reflectors these are what
actually direct signals down to earth
and each of them is custom-designed for
the region that the satellite will cover
this is for example for Telstra 18
mantich you can see here that these are
these reflectors that would be sticking
out on the sides and it's used for
sending signals back to earth and all
those little dots you see on there are
for photogrammetry so they're used to
make sure that the surface is actually
exactly as was designed so we have these
cameras that take pictures of these and
of all the dots to make sure that it was
built according to the design the
satellite these antenna reflectors
eventually went on
Telstar 18 vantage the sister satellites
of Telstar 19 vantage will launch in
late august 2018 and soon after will go
into service providing data services
over Asia and Oceania the antenna
reflector was carefully crafted to
provide signal over populated areas and
busy flight and maritime corridors while
not wasting resources on providing
service to areas the company already has
coverage for or that would have little
demand such as to the south of Australia
about 9 to 15 months after ordering the
majority of the ordered components will
start rolling through the door and then
the bulk of the assembly process begins
this process is too complex to go
into detail on but essentially they'll
first build the major elements
separately one group will assemble the
propulsion systems and framework of the
satellites while another will assemble
the payload with the satellite is
actually built to carry whether that be
an advanced camera or a communication
system well yet another group will
assemble the superlight and efficient
solar panels that will power the
satellite to win in orbit the Assembly
of the different major components will
take a few more months and then they'll
start to compile those different major
components together over a period of a
few more months each component is tested
independently before and while being
installed on the satellite but once
they're all pieced together there begins
an incredibly rigorous phase of testing
the satellites as a whole when buying a
satellite from a trusted manufacturer
like SSL the customer is buying
reliability so there can be no
compromise on testing they need to be
sure that the satellite will actually
survive launch and work in space and the
best way to do that is to just simulate
launch and space there are three major
factors that could harm a satellite
vibration temperature and sound the
vibration comes as a satellite launches
in a rocket so they tested their
satellites can survive launch when you
put one of these satellites on top of a
rocket in the payload fairing experience
a lot of vibration loads and the XY and
Z so we're able to simulate all of those
with this shaker table it has a base
plate there and even a shake in this
direction this direction or in this
direction so it does in all different
directions to simulate the environment
and make sure that it's all operating
the subtly on the table in testing here
is Telstar 19 vantage itself this here
is just one of the many tests where they
literally just shake the satellites and
see how it responds they only last about
60 to 90 seconds each because that's how
long the satellite will experience
vibration during launch until the rocket
reaches the upper atmosphere they'll
also be sure that their satellites can
survive the vacuum and temperatures of
space what you see up there this big
blue pumpkin looking thing like
Cinderella's carriage that one is called
our
thermal vacuum chamber we like to call
it the blue pumpkin and what we use it
for is for simulating the thermal vacuum
environment of space so we'll go down to
the vacuum level it's a space you know
10 to the minus 5 tour and we will turn
on the payload and different parts of
the satellite to make sure that
everything is functioning properly when
you put it in space and in addition to
that once it's under vacuum we have
these thermal panels in there to
simulate the hot and cold environments
or like when you're facing the Sun and
the satellite gets really hot we make it
we bring those temperatures to bear and
then we make it really cold when it's
facing away from Earth in the Eclipse
type of situation and make sure that
everything is functioning properly
lastly launch is very loud to the point
of the acoustic energy could actually
damage a satellite so they make sure it
doesn't by simulating the launch
environment through bombarding the
satellites with acoustic energy with
speakers there are a myriad of other
tests performed before the satellite is
given SSL stamp of approval but once
it's ready the satellite does of course
need to get to the launch site the
customer decides which launch provider
to use whether it be SpaceX United
Launch Alliance Arian space or another
so the satellite might only need to go
as far as Vandenberg Air Force Base a
four-hour drive away or as far as
Baikonur cosmodrome in Kazakhstan the
launch site is also partially decided
based off what sort of orbit this
satellite is going into if a satellite
is going to orbit in a north-south
direction over the poles they want to
launch in that direction so they want to
launch from a site with open water to
the north or south both for safety and
for some rocket designs so stages of
rockets can fall into the ocean
throughout the launch process spacex for
example therefore uses Vandenberg Air
Force Base in California for their polar
orbit launches as it has the Pacific
Ocean directly south for geosynchronous
orbits where satellites travel from west
to east at the same rate as Earth
rotates they want to launch in the same
direction as the satellites will orbit
for that reason they can't launch from
Vandenberg as it has land to the east so
SpaceX uses the launch pads on Cape
Canaveral Florida as they have the
Atlantic Ocean to the east in the case
of Telstar 19 vantage it was going in
geosynchronous orbit in order to stay
consistently over its service area so
SSL needed to get the satellite all the
way across the country to Florida no
matter where a satellite is going it
gets packed up into one of these
specialized shipping containers for
travel to close
launch sites within the US they'll often
drive they'll put the container on a
truck driven by trusted oversized
vehicle drivers have a lead vehicle
checking for obstructions a trailing
vehicle watching to make sure nothing
goes wrong and for longer drives a motor
home so drivers can swap out and rest
while still moving if the launch site is
far such as the ones overseas in French
Guiana in Kazakhstan or even the further
ones in the u.s. such as Cape Canaveral
they'll fly the satellite over in an
Antonov cargo plane satellites arrived
to their launch site at least a month
before their launch as there's plenty of
last-minute preparation to do they have
to perform additional testing to make
sure nothing was damaged in transport
fuel it up and mounted in the rocket
once that happens though there's a
period where there's really nothing for
SSL to do as they go through the process
of the countdown there are a number of
places where we're asked to confirm that
we're ready for launch and they launch
us and at that point we can no longer
monitor our satellite until we're off
the launch vehicle so for about a half
hour we're hoping that the launch people
guys are doing everything okay and they
usually are in the case of Telstar 19
Vantage the customer entrusted SpaceX
with the responsibility of getting their
satellite to orbit so on July 22nd 2018
at 1:50 a.m. a Falcon 9 rocket lifted
off from Cape Canaveral carrying SSL's
latest creation to space the launch of
this satellite actually made the record
books as it is the heaviest commercial
communication satellite to ever be
entered into service at fifteen thousand
six hundred pounds on that early morning
in July the Falcon 9 gained altitude as
it flew southeast over Africa in 32
minutes and 40 seconds after launching
358 miles above Mozambique
Telstar 19 Vantage was released from the
rocket and gently pushed forward in the
first moments of its 15 year long orbit
of Earth at that point the works not
done for SSL though their job is not
just to build the satellite but also to
enter it into service in space once the
satellite is deployed SSL will look for
its signal and establish communications
and then we start talking to the
satellite so we start commanding the
satellite we tell the satellite what we
wanted to do we start to get the
satellite into a safe position after
launch
golde deploy soil arrays so we can start
generating power
we'll start to activate everything on
the satellite and then we'll put the
satellite in a safe safe condition so
that the crew can get some rest over the
next 10 days there's a process of firing
the satellites engines to raise it from
the altitude of 350 miles where it's
deployed to 22,000 miles where it will
stay for its service life there's then
another two to four weeks of testing to
make sure everything's survived launch
and then finally after years of work
it's time to hand over the satellite to
tell us at the customer so they can put
it online and start operating it
commercially at that point after years
of work the satellite can finally itself
be put to work one of the aspects of how
satellites work that I found most
interesting to learn about when I filmed
this video was on how orbits work the
science of how you can make an object
orbit at such a consistent speed that it
will stay over one particular area of
Earth is fascinating and if you want to
learn all about how that works
brilliance teaches you exactly that in
their classical mechanics course of
course there's more than just orbits
this course provides a great overview of
physics and with brilliant you'll
actually understand the concepts rather
than just learning them they specialize
in teaching the intuitive principles
behind concepts so that you can learn
the why they also have plenty of other
fascinating courses on topics like
astronomy logic and gravitational
physics a course that teaches how
planetary orbits work all in all
brilliant is a great place to learn and
best of all you can try brilliant
classes for free by signing up at
brilliant start org slash Wendover and
then if you decide to upgrade to their
premium account the first 200 to do so
at that link will get 20% off